in the capital Brasilia demonstrations
that began peacefully turned violent
when thousands of protesters stormed the
roof of the National Congress no major
disturbances were reported in Brazil's
economic hub Sao Paulo but it was a
different story in Rio de Janeiro where
demonstrators threw firebombs at the
regional Parliament it's an outcry
against the corruption that's messing up
the country we're protesting for our
future our children health and education
there's too much misery they've done
nothing for the people and that has to
change
what started as protests against a hike
in public transport fares has become a
nationwide wave of anti-government
sentiment President Dilma Rousseff who
faces election next year has
acknowledged the protests saying
peaceful demonstrations are part of a
democracy but with world soccer focused
on the Confederations Cup the violence
is a worrying sign as Brazil prepares
for the globe's biggest sporting event
resentment is growing over the cost of
next year's World Cup estimated at more
than 10 billion euros